[Norvig] Now, one more thing.
Note that the shuffle routine--both the ones that we wrote
and the random.shuffle from the standard Python library--return None.
That is, they don't return a useful value; they just return nothing.
And the idea of the shuffle routine is that they modify the input.
So there's this eternal tension in programming between computing a result
and doing something.
So functions like square root and sine function and so on
take an input and return a result.
They don't modify the input, and they create a new value as a result.
But functions or subroutines or methods like shuffle are different.
They take an input and modify that input.
They take the state of the world and do something to the state of the world
rather than just compute a result.
We talk of these functions that compute a result as pure functions
and these that do something as impure,
and I like to talk of them as subroutines rather than functions
because they aren't functions in the mathematical sense;
they have an effect on the world.
You'll see that most of the code that I show in this class
is of the computing type rather than the doing type.
The main reason for this is that the computing code is easier to test.
So if I wanted to write a test for a computing function, for a pure function,
I can do something like assert sorted of the list ([3, 2, 1]) = [1, 2, 3].
A single line and I'm done.
On the other hand, if I want to test a subroutine that does something,
that affects the state of the world, I have to first set up some state.
So let's say input = [3, 2, 1].
Then I have to call the subroutine or method,
say input.sort,
and then I have to inspect the state to see what happened.
So I would assert that input is now equal to--oops.
Let's make sure we have double equals signs there.
Input is now equal to [1, 2, 3].
In this case there's not that much difference.
We have a library method sort and a built-in function sorted.
With the built-in function it's a single line to test.
With the doing subroutine it's 3 lines to test.
But in general, as we add more state and we have functions that do rather than compute,
it's going to be more work to set up the state, invoke the method, and then test it,
and it's easier to do the test for pure functions.
And that's why I prefer them when they make sense
and stick to the doing approach only when necessary.
When there's a lot of state that we have to deal with,
then we go ahead and write methods or subroutines that modify the state
rather than write pure functions.